[Music]
all right so
a couple days ago yeah just a couple of
days ago our nation went through
a very uh dark day i would say
january 6 2 20 21. was the day
where a mob of rioters took capitol
building
by storm ransacked it and
made a mess of our politicians uh our
our
our country that [ __ ] blew my mind yeah
me too
you for when did you find out were we
driving you told me and i was like wait
what
and when i started seeing pictures i'm
like we're supposed to be the most
powerful country in the world and we
have
like inside like perpetrators
i'm like damn that's [ __ ] crazy i
waited to get this info from you
because i knew we're gonna talk about it
but just what like just seeing the
pictures i wanted to read the caption so
bad
but i didn't but i was wondering how the
[ __ ]
did this even happen in the first place
where
our security and police didn't
grab them and kick their kick before
that might be the biggest story
out of this like watching i was like
that's really easy to get to the capitol
huh yeah
everyone was like we could steal the
declaration of independence
isn't the capital isn't it isn't it a
public place though
because like there's protests that
happen all the time obviously then we
don't hear about it because it's not as
they went
inside yeah no no i know that but i
showed up with uh bulletproof vest
bulletproof helmets they were ready for
some wild [ __ ] and for some reason
the cops basically there's like footage
i mean i'm not gonna i'm just so much
footage i'm not gonna show any footage
but basically
there were there were cops seeing like
opening doors for people
holding the hands of a woman as she's
leaving the capitol hill like just like
letting her like oh yeah there you go
you know get home safe you know that
kind of attitude and twitter went off
twitter like you know basically it's
like hey when george floyd stuff
happened
and uh blm took over where's the tear
guys i was trying to make a statement
yeah like that was a very different
response than than
what they did at capitol hill yeah on
the other side so i don't know the
actual like i don't know the reason why
why was so easy to like enter but i
don't know if it has to do with either
the logistical of
uh defunding the police where now they
are under staff because i know at least
for like lapd
like they've pulled a lot of patrol cars
off the street because they got defunded
like crazy
um like the cop per like square mile is
now
drastically decreased so i don't know if
that is the same case in dc where if
they have i don't know 10 guards now
they're
down to five and then also the other
side of it
um that i have seen which is kind of
unfortunate is
um some people are like this is what you
asked for
so i don't know if it's like that kind
of sentiment too so it's kind of scary i
don't know if the numbers thing makes
sense because it was
it wasn't like a spur of the moment they
appeared out of nowhere
it was like a planned event you know and
like let's say they have a planned march
here
they put out extra cops because there's
a planned march or a planned thing where
they're like
just in case something happens we'll put
out extra people that's the part where i
think it's the emotional sentiment part
where if there are bitter cops right i'm
not saying that they are but
if there are bitter cops and they
already hate the people for defending
them
how easy is it for them to know because
we all i've also seen pictures of where
it looks like
the cops are just letting them in yeah
there was the one where it was like the
barricade
right and they just kind of moved the
barricade is it their way of trying to
get back
at what happened i mean i don't know
yeah yeah it makes sense but it's also
that's not gonna help anything yeah
everyone's so emotional and pissed off
no one's making any smart moves but this
is also kind of like you know if you're
gonna look at like the sides involved
right
so the initial you know protests that
happened in our country
was uh you know uh
blind police injustice and police and
justice and then a lot of antifa
uh people going out into the public and
just you know
causing a lot of uh you know problems
and then
this time though it wasn't necessarily
antifa and blm
and you know the left-wing groups they
were there
they were there but i think a bigger
portion of them
were mega trump supporters for sure
mainly them yeah and uh i mean there's a
lot of speculation that
um you know the the mega people were
the the the the sophisticated
quiet like emerges here peaceful types
and then the real people that were
causing the problems were
the antifa but that's you know i just
did a video of uh
antifa guys smashing the window and all
the mega people were like stop stop and
then they pulled them
out and then they he went back to the
antifa crowd
right but there's also a lot of videos
showing the mega people
like just like bum rushing they're bomb
rushing capitol hill and pushing through
the plane
yeah like one lady got shot right in the
chest like she was crawling through a
broken window they broke the window and
you in the video you can see a
a cop like like basically holding up the
gun you can't really hear what he's
saying but he's literally holding the
gun for like
10 seconds and just like hey come on
like what are you going to do what are
you doing like stop that
and then you shot her she falls from and
it's a high window she falls like maybe
a good like six feet
and then she just like she's like
lifeless the moment she falls
that's stupid right like what makes you
think you can break into
property and not get shot what also
shows how stupid they are because you
see
the like the people bum rush go in right
[ __ ] yeah
and they run in and once they get in
they're like
we're inside what do we do how do we
change the government
yeah get the papers yeah what papers are
on the ground
throw it that's the papers and they're
like take a picture of me
yeah it's just like once they get it
they didn't know what to do doing a
podium
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] and then also
i've been seeing other
side stories come out of this like for
example there's this dude that
went in with his company badge card
and he got fired because it's like why
the [ __ ] would you go in there
representing the company here's there's
a there's a level of privilege to be had
when you do certain things
and you don't expect to get hurt yeah
like the lady climbing into a window i'm
assuming
high level privilege when you're
climbing over cops or whatever and where
people are pointing guns at you and
you're thinking in your head there's no
way they're going to shoot me
it's a racial thing hell yeah why people
are way more brave
against the police they're not black i
can't be shot and they just go
they just go for it other people get to
like second guess yourself right where
you're like am i gonna get
hurt here and then you have to go okay
even if i get hurt i'll do it anyways
you know and but then there are
the other people who are like there's no
way pop that had his knee on george
floyd like
he was there for that long knowing like
i'm not gonna get any consequences for
that it's like even dave chappelle
you know when he did the skit right
where he's like if he has his white
friend in the car
they treat him differently it's a
thousand percent true
but the problem is a lot of white people
can't see it because they never lived it
yeah they've never seen the other side
they never seen the other side they
never experienced it
and for them the police is someone they
can rely on they can call for help
whatever but for us we've been on both
sides it's like
if you're asian guy that looks clean cut
with money the cops are on your side
but if you have a bald head and you
dress a certain way
they're against you and it doesn't
matter like i think it's just
really about if you fit the profile or
not
and if you fit the profile you don't
vibe with the culture you don't look
like one of them or you don't look like
a safe person
what ends up happening is you're a
criminal you're
a criminal like i'm gonna treat you like
one you're a criminal by
association yeah and then their job is
to
find criminals and arrest them so if you
look like one
you know they don't have the time to
think and be like
uh is this person good or bad they're
like oh he fits it let me pull him over
all right
what can i get him on all right i'm
gonna do this and this and then this
isn't
right or wrong i'm saying that this is
the thought process that goes behind
policing and they do this repetitively
non-stop
so it it becomes a number you're not a
human being you become a statistic right
so what happened with the mega people
showing up wearing their maga stuff
there's like red white and blue and
stuff and
and they're painting over him viking
horns and stuff did that not look
criminal
or like the fact that they were even
acting out the way they did that didn't
look criminal enough for the cops to do
it in my opinion though
i don't know what the cops are thinking
like in that specific sense but like i'm
just talking
just what i've experienced in la and how
we get
treated differently but also if you
think about it like
even within to me it's more like
dominant culture right even within
white folks if you are white with a bald
head
and you look you don't look a part of
society
right and then like let's say you look
like a skinhead or a gangster or like
maybe you look like white trash quote
unquote the cops are gonna treat you
like [ __ ]
just the same they're not gonna i've
seen it happen like they don't treat
them like a white kid from huntington
beach that's clean cut
you know what i mean like i think it's
more of a do you fit the description of
someone who's likely to commit a crime
and then that's where the whole racism
and stereotypes and stuff like that come
from
when they look at this i don't know what
they're thinking because to me
i never seen a white guy with a raccoon
thing on his head
running around naked outside of a sports
event well here's the thing too i feel
like uh like bart was saying there's so
much emotion right and i feel like
cops are also victim to their own
emotions and how they feel absolutely
they're human so when you
think if you compare a protest that's
literally against cops
you know and then how you're gonna feel
as a cop being at an event where
everyone's against you whether or not
it's peaceful right
so they're gonna be they might be more
aggressive compared to let's say
this march at the capitol people have
blue line flags and they're like these
guys
are in favor of me yeah so like whether
or not i think they're gonna commit a
crime these guys
are in favor of me so we're not maybe
we're on the same team
or something compared to you know for a
fact even if
uh this other march is peaceful you know
they're against you
yeah so like then you have your emotion
playing effectively your tension
tension is higher or lower and whenever
we mention these things too like it's
you can't get it confused with us
arguing for morality or what's ethical
it's not really about right or wrong
here it's really about understanding
the motives in the situation so for
example with like even
adding on to nelson's point right like
the whole
why cops might not care or whatever
or maybe they feel like these guys are
on their side
is because we have to do that we have to
make the effort of trying to understand
you know um how they feel as a human
being because professionally they're
expected
to do their job but since it's a human
behind that badge
you also have to understand that bias
that comes along with it
so like in this situation are they all
racist white cops i don't know i think
that's just an
easy out like to to to blanket it that
way
i feel like cops are multicultural
and they themselves are human beings
that are like
why do a lot of people [ __ ] want us
out why do they hate us
like you know what i mean yeah so
setting the whole cop
dilemma thing aside trump supporters
stormed the capital because they wanted
to
change the electoral college votes they
want to stop the accounting again
the county right so but then what they
ended up doing was further hurting their
cause because there was a lot of people
that
that were in in in that whole space
saying like well i was going to decide
this thing but after this happened i'm
doing this
what's it the georgia senator or
whatever yeah she was like about to
dissent and all of a sudden she was like
i was going to dissent today but after
this [ __ ] you made it worse
i'm not going to say anything now yeah a
lot of people are pointing fingers back
at trump like even pence is in a
position where he's like
dude i was going to ride or die ride and
die with you but this is kind of like
the the final straw man like everyone's
basically leaving trump's side
and yeah because i don't know how true
this is but i saw a screenshot of trump
saying
uh tweeting like i'll see you january
6th i don't know if that's
yeah no no these are all all these
tweets have been taken down now
but like that's like evidence that he
was behind
planning this whole thing i mean even
the day before like on january 5th he
was at a rally telling them to go to the
march
and he was saying fight and stuff like
that i saw this meme of kim jong-un
saying i thought i was crazy
i was like that's a good one so i was i
was following the election pretty
closely
yeah and why something like this can
like boil it makes
sense to me right because you have
two different complete worlds colliding
where like you have people who um
accept and understand that like okay
biden's gonna be coming into office
and then you have a whole different
group of people who are like that
election was
stolen by um big media
big tech and you have trump echoing the
same thing
and saying that he's not going to let it
happen basically so like the guys that
stormed the capital
they believe that they're trying that
they're saving america
and the integrity behind america and
then you you see the rest of the world
looking at them like that's not the
right way to do it bro but then they're
desperate
so then when people get desperate they
get crazy and that's what i don't want
to see
and i'm like come on dude trump's gotta
like take it a notch back and
and if he is trying to deal with it even
if there was corruption even if there
was voter fraud do it smart
yeah because in my opinion this isn't
smart it divides the nation exactly be
dignified about
you know your loss you're losing the the
election no no he did didn't he
like finally he yeah after after twitter
had a censor him basically banned him
for 12 hours
uh facebook and instagram banned him for
the next two weeks until president
yeah rest of his presidency he could
have left gracefully
and made a comeback in four years if
biden didn't do such a good job
like he ruined his [ __ ] chances
he's not gonna stop rallying i i don't
he still might come back in four years i
mean even he
even when he finally said yeah bond's
gonna take the presidency now like
he still says this isn't over we're
still yeah he still had to say that well
like
no i mean you know since he became
president he never stopped rallying
so do you think when he's done being
president he's going to stop rallying i
think he's still going to rally i think
he's still going to rally
i'm talking about um increasing his
possibility of a second term
is now killed because of this reason
that's what we thought when he first ran
i don't know he's gonna come back around
and to close out this video
uh ironically mitch mcconnell uh who is
a senator a republican senator uh
right before the magamobs stormed the
capitol hill
he was making a speech um and he was
talking about how
at this time it it's not a good idea
to form a mob and to fight back
you know with force and stuff because it
would just
it would prove a point that america is
not stable enough
to be democratic you know and like and
even if the if the
if the vote was stolen it's still not
right to be violent
and it would set a president if this
were to happen
this will set a president for future
elections to just
encourage people to be like in four
years when we go through another
election
it just might be the new normal to just
to bring arms in
and just like riot and like destroy
things and it's just it's not a good
look and
it's it's it's going to rewire our
brains politically
and then as a country so he was saying
stop it
even though giuliani's saying uh
giuliani literally said in during a
speech he said
so let's have trial by combat literally
you know it's like what the [ __ ] are you
thinking
yeah [ __ ] giuliani man why does he
even have a voice
after [ __ ] getting caught almost
man i don't know i think what's
separates us from i think
a lot of unstable nations is
the fact that we still haven't yet
got to that point since the civil war
of armed internal combat
and it's every it's been through the
mind and through legislation and through
politics right
but if you look at examples of unstable
nations that constantly have
military coups and rebellions and
infighting
like we can easily get there people
think we're like
hella [ __ ] impenetrable and like
we're solid but it's like no we can get
there
and we have the guns to do it but like
[ __ ] man i don't want to
get there because i love this country
and i hope that we can stay above that
and and do it through the mind you know
yeah well
i guess we'll find out
you